Нова доплата за газ, висока ціна
Споживачі шукають шляхи виходу з газової кризи
Скандальний Орбан, зусилля ЄС
Європа бореться за єдність проти Путіна
Музиканти-біженці, цілюща музика
Український оркестр свободи грає у Варшаві
А зараз - «heute journal»
із Ханною Ціммерман та Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Доброго вечора всім.
Те, що життя в Німеччині стане дорожчим, було зрозуміло й раніше,
але сьогодні ми вже маємо більше подробиць.
По перше, це витрати на енергію, які зросли,
що багато хто помітить лише тоді,
коли отримає наступний рахунок за комунальні послуги.
Але тоді ми це справді помітимо. І дуже добре.
Поряд із цим держава вводить доплату за газ
для всіх споживачів,
щоб підтримати імпортерів газу,
які опинилися в скрутному становищі.
Точний розмір доплати поки не відомий.
За словами міністра економіки,
він коливатиметься між 1,5 і 5 центами за кВт-год.
Розгляньмо це детальніше:
Якщо взяти класичний варіант домогосподарства з 4-х осіб,
у якому річний обсяг спожитого газу становить 20 тис. кВт-год,
то разом із ПДВ це вийде додаткова сума
між 357 і 1190 євро на рік.
Як я вже сказав, це плюс до рахунку за газ від постачальника.
Що може допомогти? Економія.
Як це найкраще зробити? Дізнавалася Зузана Зантіна.
Наскільки зростуть їхні витрати через доплату за газ,
Мара і Даніель Кірберґ поки не можуть порахувати,
але те, що ціни мають знову зрости,
їх неприємно здивувало.
Ефективним для зниження витрат
вони вважають переобладнання будинку, щоб зробити його більш енергоощадним.
Якщо, наприклад, ідеться про ізоляцію,
вони могли б багато чого зробити самі.
Ці витрати будуть ще відносно посильними.
Ми сподіваємося, що за таких умов
за 1-2 роки
ми зможемо їх компенсувати.
У котельні сьогодні поважний відвідувач.
Міністр економіки Гессена Тарік Аль-Вазір
подорожує федеральною землею,
щоб дати людям поради щодо енергозаощадження.
Сьогодні він зустрівся із сім'єю Кірберґ
разом із консультанткою зі споживання енергії та орендодавицею.
Тут є над чим працювати.
Неізольовані труби опалення та неперекрита стеля в підвалі.
Від орендарів я також дізналася,
що ще не було проведено гідравлічне балансування.
Оскільки тут лише нещодавно було встановлено новий газовий котел,
можна розраховувати на те,
що витрати на енергію знизяться приблизно на 30%.
Навіть якщо взяти за приклад Гессен,
тут налічується 3 млн домогосподарств.
Якщо кожне з цих домогосподарств
скоротить споживання енергії на 10-15%,
то загальний ефект буде дійсно помітним.
Саме так можна отримати відповідь на запитання:
«Переживемо ми цю зиму
без російського газу чи ні?»
Але питання також у тому, хто має за це платити?
Теплові насоси, нові вікна або обігрівачі можуть здорожчати.
Передбачену компенсацію витрат
на переобладнання можна отримати лише постфактум.
І найбільшу частину люди все ж мають сплачувати самостійно.
Ми повністю підтримуємо ідею щодо компенсації,
щоб люди, які хочуть зробити переобладнання,
але не мають на це коштів, усе ж могли це зробити.
Наприклад, багато домовласників -
це люди похилого віку,
які навряд чи можуть розраховувати на приватні кредити,
адже банки не видають кредити людям віком більше 70 років.
Тому їм необхідна грошова допомога.
Газ дорогий і його мало.
Президент Росії Путін усе більше скорочує поставки для Німеччини,
тому терміново шукають альтернативи.
Об'єднання підприємств цифрової економіки «Bitkom»
бачить великий потенціал
у приблизно 3000 центрів обробки даних, які знаходяться в Німеччині.
90 із них мають достатню величину
та найбільш придатне відпрацьоване тепло.
Лише ці 90 центрів обробки даних могли б опалювати 350 тис. помешкань
впродовж усього року.
Наразі ми не використовуємо цю можливість.
Щоб це зробити, нам потрібно ось що:
розширення мереж централізованого опалення,
додаткові теплообмінники, які підвищують температуру.
Також потрібно вирішити питання щодо плати за мережу.
Вона має бути безкоштовною,
адже ми і так заощаджуватимемо багато енергії.
Одне можна сказати точно: в Німеччині є проблема
не лише з газом, а й із майстрами у цій сфері.
Їх бракує.
Марі та Даніелю Кірберґ не обов'язково чекати на майстрів.
Вони хочуть якомога швидше самостійно подбати
про ізоляцію труб опалення та перекриття стелі в підвалі.
У «heute journal update» о 00:30
буде відповідати на запитання експерт
аналітичного центру «Agora-Energiewende».
Санкції проти Росії
мають ударити по Росії більше, ніж по нас самих.
Таким був план.
І був певний період часу,
коли багатьом санкції здавалися
недостатньо швидкими та ефективними.
Настільки сильним був шок і розпач
через жахливу війну Президента Росії
проти України.
Я кажу «був», тому що, хоча війна ще не закінчилася,
але ситуація із санкціями вже дещо змінилася.
Головному дипломату ЄС у європейських столицях
чітко висловлюють сумніви щодо санкційної політики проти Росії,
вживаючи слово «помилка».
Очевидно, європейська солідарність дещо похитнулася.
Це навіть не враховуючи угорця Віктора Орбана,
який усе радикальніше висловлюється проти своїх європейських партнерів.
Далі - Флоріан Нойган.
Це сьогоднішня зустріч двох очільників урядів однієї спільноти
з ліберальними та демократичними цінностями - ЄС.
Або ж ні.
Це зустріч австрійського демократа
та Віктора Орбана, угорського...
Кого ж усе-таки?
Він уже й так показав себе як антидемократ і антиєвропеєць.
А тепер ми чітко бачимо, що він також і расист,
який не соромиться
послуговуватися фашистськими ідеями.
Нещодавно Орбан знову перетнув межу.
Субота,
Прем'єр-міністр Угорщини застерігає від життя у світі,
«де європейські народи змішуються з людьми з-поза меж Європи.
Ми не хочемо ставати змішаною расою».
Це схоже на висловлювання нацистів,
яке сьогодні
розкритикували навіть у меморіалі Голокосту «Яд Вашем».
Але Орбан захищає свою думку і далі:
Я не хочу, щоб міграція до Угорщини посилювалася.
Я завжди притримувався цієї точки зору
і робитиму це надалі.
Це не має жодних біологічних підстав.
Це не питання расизму, це питання культури.
Від лідерів ЄС жодної реакції.
Якщо не брати до уваги
обережне дистанціювання федерального канцлера Австрії Негаммера.
Що мене найбільше дивує,
і в сенсі чого я б висловила критику в бік лідерів держав та урядів ЄС,
це те, що в них самих немає «червоних ліній»,
вони знову і знову миряться з цим.
Орбан уже не вперше
перетинає «червону лінію».
Він також усе частіше блокує рішення
на засіданнях Європейської ради.
Орбан проти всіх -
цими днями це вже звична історія для Брюсселя,
передусім у питанні політики щодо Росії.
Спочатку він блокує нафтове ембарго. Потім накладає вето
на план на випадок нестачі газу, проте його долають.
Також він посилає свого міністра закордонних справ до Москви
із завданням попросити більше російського газу.
Це теж одне з бажань Путіна -
розділити ЄС -
і Орбан, на жаль, сприяє цьому.
Якщо говорити чесно,
то, крім Угорщини з її тотальною блокадою, серед скептиків уже давно
почали з'являтися представники й інших країн ЄС,
які хоча й не такі жорсткі, як Орбан,
але вже й не так вірять у санкції,
як це було спочатку.
Лідери деяких держав та урядів ЄС заявили,
що санкції були помилкою.
Я не вважаю, що вони були помилкою.
Ми мусили це робити.
І ми робитимемо це й надалі.
Але для будь-яких інших рішень
ЄС потребує згоди також і від Віктора Орбана.
Можливо, саме тому критика в його бік є такою стриманою.
Флоріане, чи можуть сумніви щодо санкцій,
які головний дипломат ЄС
уже спостерігає в деяких європейських столицях,
призвести до того,
що ці санкції буде знято,
попри те, що ситуація з війною не змінилася?
Офіційне зняття санкцій було б занадто серйозним кроком,
на який ЄС, однозначно, не наважиться.
Але в Брюсселі помітно,
що дискурс значно змінився.
На санкції вже не покладають таких надій, як раніше.
Раніше після запровадження одного пакета
відразу починали обговорювати наступний,
проте після останнього саміту лідери багатьох держав та урядів заявили,
що наступного пакета поки не буде.
Це пов'язано також і з тим,
що попередні пакети реалізовано не повністю.
Наприклад, щодо енергетичної політики.
Європа ухвалила 2 ембарго на російське вугілля та нафту,
але, по перше, жодне з них ще не набуло чинності,
ми ще до кінця цього року купуватимемо російську нафту.
По-друге, багато урядів побоюються зростання
невдоволення серед населення через підвищення цін на енергоносії.
І по-третє, у Брюсселі помітно певне відчуття безсилля через те,
що санкції діють не так швидко, як деякі сподівалися.
Європа починає розуміти, що тут варто набратися терпіння,
набагато більшого, ніж очікувалося спочатку.
- Дякую, Флоріане.
Війна в Україні також посилює катастрофу,
яка відбувається поза великими заголовками,
але яка неодмінно їх варта, адже те,
що там відбувається саме зараз, день у день,
є соромом для сучасного світу.
Зараз ми покажемо кадри, які важко сприймати:
маленькі діти, немовлята,
яким занадто довго не було що їсти,
які надто слабкі, щоб плакати. Вони вмирають.
Кількість мешканців Сомалі, країни Східної Африки,
які зазнають сильного голоду,
зросла втричі за останні пів року.
Чверть мільйона людей перебувають на межі смерті,
адже вже чотири роки у регіоні не було дощу,
а зараз туди надходить занадто мало допомоги.
Детальніше - Пітер Сміт і Камран Сафяріан.
Ці люди мандрують уже кілька днів.
Зневірені, вони шукають їжу й воду -
втомлені, виснажені, голодні.
Їхні села розташовані за сотні кілометрів.
Фатіма бачила на власні очі,
як вмирала від голоду одна з її дітей.
Тепер голодна смерть загрожує ще одній дитині.
«Моя дитина вмирає від голоду, у неї блювота, діарея,
гарячка й недоїдання».
Це - табір Кагарі в районі Долоу на Заході Сомалі.
На початку року тут проживало 60 тис. осіб,
а зараз - 146 тис.
Багато хто сподівається
врятуватися тут від голодної смерті.
Від неї страждають найслабші.
На цій станції допомагають
стабілізувати найскладніші ситуації.
Челіка страждає від сильного голоду.
Їй чотири роки, та вона важить, як однорічне немовля.
Ізмаїлу нещодавно виповнився рік.
Без лікування він би вже давно помер.
Половина всіх сомалійських дітей страждає від голоду.
Щодня в Сомалі гине дитина.
Команда медиків перевіряє ознаки недоїдання.
Цей хлопчик перебуває в «червоній зоні».
«Нам просто потрібно більше їжі.
Це найголовніше.
Лікування препаратами недостатньо».
Недоїдання також сприяє поширенню хвороб,
як-от холери або туберкульозу.
Алі змушений ховати вже свою четверту дитину.
«Мій син захворів, він мав діарею й біль у животі,
а потім він просто перестав їсти».
Причиною голоду є
найсильніша посуха за останні десятиліття.
Чотири рази поспіль сезон дощів проходив без дощу.
Покинуті домівки, неврожайні поля,
загибла худоба, від якої залежить життя багатьох людей.
«Вся худоба вдома загинула, криниці висохли.
Деякі з нас так ослабли від голоду,
що ми були вимушені залишити їх».
Ситуацію ускладнює те, що Сомалі
імпортувала понад 90% пшениці
з Росії та України.
Однак тепер транспортні лінії заблоковано,
а ціни неймовірно зросли.
ООН попереджає про можливе
масове вимирання населення.
«Це не просто черговий період засухи.
Це найстрашніша посуха за останні 40 років.
Тож світ має звернути увагу на Сомалі
через руйнівні масштаби біди».
З кожним днем тих,
хто не витримує цієї біди, стає дедалі більше.
Тим часом у табір прибуває дедалі більше людей.
Жінка падає на землю.
У дорозі вона народила дитину.
Після цього мати пройшла ще 5 кілометрів.
Це хлопчик, він здоровий.
Та чи надовго?
Ці люди не можуть повпливати на ситуацію у світі.
Та вони платять найвищу ціну.
Ханно, розкажи нам про поточну ситуацію в Україні.
Там тривають бої.
Також уперше за кілька тижнів
російські військові завдали ударів
по Київщині й Чернігівщині,
які вже тривалий час не зазнавали обстрілів.
Тим часом на Херсонщині
українська сторона здійснює успішний контрнаступ.
Про це повідомляє військова розвідка Великої Британії.
Так, українським військовим вдалося
пошкодити щонайменше три мости,
які є важливими шляхами постачання
для російської армії.
Міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини Бербок
здійснила візит у Грецію,
а завтра відвідає Туреччину.
Окрім війни в Україні, темою візитів є також
напруга між двома країнами-членами НАТО.
Між Грецією та Туреччиною вже давно існує конфлікт
щодо володіння родовищем природного газу
в Середземному морі.
В Афінах Бербок також вшанувала
жертв масштабних злочинів
німецької окупаційної влади
у часи Другої світової війни.
Вимоги про компенсаційні виплати
міністерка закордонних справ відхилила.
Лідер партії CDU Мерц
зустрівся у Польщі
з прем'єр-міністром країни Моравецьким,
щоб обговорити питання
постачання зброї в Україну.
Причиною для зустрічі
стало невдоволення уряду Польщі
через проблеми з «круговим обміном»
зброєю з Німеччиною.
Своїм візитом Мерц випередив уряд Німеччини.
Убивство очільника адміністративного округу Кассель Вальтера Любке
було предметом розгляду сьогодні
у Верховному суді Німеччини у місті Карлсруе.
У січні 2021 року правого екстреміста Штефана Ернста
було засуджено за вбивство до довічного ув'язнення.
Зі співвідповідача Маркуса Х.
було знято звинувачення у співучасті.
Через попередній вирок
усі учасники процесу подали апеляцію,
тож Верховний суд перевіряє
наявність юридичних помилок.
Ухвалення рішення очікують у кінці серпня.
Вальтера Любке застрелили
влітку 2019 року на терасі його будинку.
За розрахунками міжнародної організації
«Global Footprint Network»,
сьогодні для населення Землі настав
так званий день екологічного боргу.
Так називають день,
коли люди в усьому світі використали всі ресурси,
які планета здатна відновити за рік у природний спосіб.
У багатьох розвинутих країнах цей день
настав ще раніше:
у Німеччині - 4 травня.
Панує спека, та передусім - посуха.
У районах лісових пожеж у Бранденбурзі та Саксонії
сотні пожежників борються
проти осередків пожеж, які постійно займаються -
вже четвертий день поспіль.
Вітер змінив напрям,
і ситуація у Саксонській Швейцарії погіршилася.
У постраждалих районах важко добути воду для гасіння,
тому гелікоптери є особливо важливими
для роботи пожежників.
Але річка Ельба, яка мала б бути джерелом води для них,
сама має занадто мало її.
Як і багато інших річок у Німеччині.
«Обміління» — так називають цю ситуацію
річкові перевізники на Рейні,
які через це більше не можуть
виходити на воду з повним навантаженням.
Це ще одна погана новина, особливо для компаній,
залежних від суднових перевезень.
Це як доміно: один камінчик валить наступний.
Детальніше - Лотар Бекер.
Тисяча тонн вівса
для компанії «Fortin Mühlenwerke».
Її очільник Роберт Ламерс залюбки б
купив ще зерна в Роттердамі.
Проте зараз один корабель
не може перевозити більше в Дюссельдорф
через низький рівень води в Рейні.
Натомість необхідно платити додатково 150% від суми
за низький рівень води.
Якщо за звичайних обставин
фрахт становив 10 тис. євро,
зараз я плачу 10 тис. євро за
вантажоперевезення і доплату в розмірі 15 тис. євро.
Тобто загалом це 25 тис. євро замість 10 тис.
для перевезення товару в Дюссельдорф.
При цьому ситуація в Нижньому Рейні
ще відносно спокійна.
Найвужче місце Рейна
розташоване за 200 км вгору за течією в місті Кауб.
Рівень води в цьому фарватері зараз особливо низький.
Щоб не сісти на мілину, перевізник Лео Доомс
завантажив борт менш як на третину
від допустимої вантажності.
Разом зі своєю дружиною Маріє він перевозить
1100 тонн товару замість 3900
з Людвіґсгафена в Амстердам.
Можливо, менші кораблі можуть знову курсувати далі вгору за течією,
але якщо рівень води біля Кауба становитиме 30-40 см,
то для нас рух буде неможливим.
Уже зараз у деяких місцях бракує стільки води,
що між корпусом судна й дном Рейна
можна вмістити лише ящик з напоями.
Хоча за низького рівня води
корисного простору для вантажу завжди мало,
цього разу ситуацію погіршують ще інші чинники.
Усім відомо, що ми відновлюємо вугільну енергетику.
Це означає, що велика частина
транспортних потужностей
буде потрібна для перевезення вугілля.
Річкові вантажні судна також направлять у Дунай,
щоб допомогти Україні експортувати зерно.
Через війну в Україні надзвичайно зросли
ціни на енергоносії та зерно
для заводу з виготовлення вівсяних пластівців
Роберта Ламерса в Дюссельдорфі.
Однак у питанні постачання, ймовірно, альтернативи
річковим перевезенням немає.
Ми планували використовувати залізницю
у 2018 році, коли рівень води теж був низьким.
Це значно дорожче,
тому що спад рівня води просто неможливо планувати.
Довелося би брати в оренду вагони на цілий рік,
навіть не знаючи, чи будуть вони потрібні.
Вантажівки - це, звісно, також екологічне питання.
Щоб замінити одне річкове судно,
яке перевозить наш вантаж раз на тиждень,
потрібно 140 вантажівок.
Поки Рейн пристосується
до, ймовірно, частіших маловодних фаз,
можуть минути роки,
якщо не десятиліття.
Тому, певно, зростання цін через падіння рівня води
у майбутньому буде радше правилом.
Це ще один приклад того, як усе пов'язано з усім:
кліматична криза й рівень води в річках,
рівень води в річках і ланцюги постачання.
Є ще дещо, пов'язане між собою:
високі ціни на енергоносії
та серйозні побоювання для одних,
високі ціни на енергоносії та великі прибутки для інших.
Спершу погляньмо на побоювання.
Рівень інфляція в Німеччині залишається високим:
згідно із даними Федерального відомства статистики
у липні він становить 7,5%.
Однак це вже друге невелике зниження рівня інфляції і,
звичайно, це дає надію, що
інфляція може втратити темпи росту у довгостроковій перспективі.
Стефані Баррет із нами на зв'язку.
Як це розцінювати?
Насправді питання полягає в тому,
чи досягли ми вже вершини.
Напевно, ще ні.
У вересні закінчується термін дії антиінфляційних заходів,
як-от пільговий квиток за 9 євро та знижка на пальне.
Тому рівень інфляції може бути більшим ніж 8%,
але темпи росту, можливо, сповільняться.
Ми дізнаємося більше інформації завтра вранці,
коли будуть оголошені економічні показники за квартал.
Експерти очікують мінімального зростання у кращому разі.
Водночас споживачі стримуються від покупок
та заощаджують гроші.
Попит падає,
тому й ціни можуть знизитися.
Але про розслаблення і заспокоєння не може бути й мови.
Зростання цін на продукти харчування на 15%
досягло загрозливих масштабів.
Не кажучи вже про ціни на енергоносії.
- Але є й компанії, які отримують переваги
від збільшення цін на енергоносії:
у компанії «Shell» та інших з цієї «команди» дзвенять гаманці.
Нафтові компанії мають найбільше переваг у цій кризі,
особливо від початку війни в Україні.
Через санкції обсяги російської нафти зменшились,
що спричинило зростання цін на нафту на світовому ринку.
Рівень прибутку нафтопереробних заводів також значно зріс.
За останні роки було закрито дуже багато таких заводів
через наміри відмовитися від викопних джерел енергії.
Найбільші нафтові концерни отримують великі прибутки також
від продажів електроенергії та газу.
Лише за 3 місяці найбільша європейська нафтова компанія «Shell»
заробила на 6 млрд євро більше,
ніж у тому ж кварталі минулого року.
Також подвоїли свої прибутки компанії
«Total Energy» із Франції і «Repsol» з Іспанії.
Безсумнівно, нафтові компанії заробляють величезні гроші.
Це викликає питання про участь
нафтових транснаціональних компаній
у допомозі промисловості та споживачам.
Деякі європейські країни вже вимагають
від нафтових компаній сплачувати спеціальні податки,
інші - тільки планують такі заходи.
Зрештою, комісія ЄС вже дала «зелене світло»
на такий обмежений за часом податок на надприбуток.
Дякую, Стефані, за коментар.
Після двох років збитків Deutsche Bahn знову в плюсі:
У першому півріччі державна компанія змогла досягти
операційного прибутку 876 млн євро.
Deutsche Bahn завдячує цим насамперед своїй
логістичній дочірній компанії DB Schenker,
яка отримала мільярди.
Крім того, після гострих періодів пандемії
збільшилася кількість мандрівників.
Для подорожей між містами на далекі відстані залізницею
скористалося близько 59 млн мандрівників.
Це вдвічі більше, ніж за аналогічний період
минулого року.
53 перемоги, чотири титули чемпіона світу,
а тепер - завершення кар'єри:
Себастьян Феттель, один із найуспішніших
гонщиків в історії Формули-1,
завершує свою кар'єру після цього сезону.
35-річний гонщик пояснив у своєму відеозвернені,
що хоче проводити більше часу зі своєю сім'єю.
За час перебування у команді Red Bull
гонщик із Геппенгайма виграв чотири титули поспіль.
Але ні в Ferrari, ні в Aston Martin
йому не вдалося повторити свій успіх.
Останнім часом Феттель все більше виступає
за захист клімату та права людини.
Музика не допомагає забути,
оскільки і не хочеться забувати.
Музика є орієнтиром.
«Це було на кшталт психотерапії», -
кажуть музиканти,
які святкують особливу прем'єру сьогодні у Варшаві.
Позаду 10 днів інтенсивних репетицій.
Це неймовірно мало часу для оркестру,
який хоче гастролювати світом,
а більшість його учасників ніколи раніше не грали разом.
Але в них є дещо, що їх об'єднує:
всі вони з України.
І грають заради свободи.
* «З Нового світу» Антонін Дворжак *
«Новий світ» Дворжака
у виконанні новоствореного оркестру.
Професійні музиканти, які грають у різних
філармоніях світу,
вперше проводять репетицію разом,
але вже тривалий час пов'язані один з одним.
Ми всі друзі, ми брати й сестри з однієї країни.
Ми говоримо однією мовою.
Неважливо, хто де живе зараз.
Але кожен відчуває тугу за Батьківщиною.
Ще до війни Михайло Стефко грав першу скрипку
в Угорській національній філармонії в Будапешті.
Його батьки живуть в Україні.
Своїх онуків вони бачать лише по відео.
Марко Комонько встиг виїхати з України
разом зі своїми 3 дітьми
незабаром після вторгнення Росії.
Зараз він живе у Швеції.
Буквально кілька днів тому Адріан Боднар
приїхав автобусом зі Львова.
Для нас це велика честь, тому що це не просто гастролі.
Це можливість знову привернути увагу до того,
що зараз відбувається в Україні.
Кері-Лінн Вілсон -
диригентка із Канади з українським корінням.
Її двоюрідні брати воюють зараз на Донбасі.
«Оркестр свободи» був її ідеєю.
Я мріяла про створення такого оркестру ще з моменту
вторгнення Росії на територію України,
щоб показати солідарність і боротися за майбутнє України
на культурному фронті.
Протягом місяця оркестр гастролюватиме містами Європи
та в Нью-Йорку на знак протесту проти війни.
Невипадково тур починається у Варшаві,
у місті, яке під час Другої світової війни
гітлерівці зрівняли із землею.
Ми просимо наших друзів з України
подивитися на Варшаву
і повірити, що можливо відбудувати місто
та наповнити його життям.
Це реально і це можна втілити в життя.
Оскільки українським чоловікам призовного віку
зараз заборонено залишати країну,
президент Зеленський надав музикантам винятковий дозвіл на виїзд.
Після турне вони знову повернуться в Україну.
У мене там сім'я, діти,
а також робота.
Ми повернемося у будь-якому випадку,
оскільки віримо, що ситуація покращиться.
Ми переможемо, іншого шляху немає.
2 години тому вже розпочався концерт
«Українського оркестру свободи» у Варшаві.
На початку виконують «Симфонію № 7»
українського композитора Валентина Сильвестрова.
84-річний композитор виїхав до Берліну через війну.
Це був репортаж Сюзанни Польман
про «Український оркестр свободи».
Повністю концерт можна переглянути в медіатеці Arte,
а в неділю на телеканалі Arte з 17:10.
Таким був наш світ сьогодні.
Завтра та на вихідних у студії Вас вітатимуть
Ґундула Ґаузе і Мітрі Зірін.
Ми повернемося наступного тижня.
Рекомендуємо переглянути «heute journal up:date»
о 0:30 із Назан Гекдемір.
Добрий вечір.
Зараз циклон «Фріда» витісняє антициклон «Міка»
на південь Швеції.
Це означає, що ми очікуємо дощі, зливи та грози.
Сьогодні ввечері у північній частині Німеччини
вплив антициклону «Міка» буде відчутним -
там стане холодно.
Температура впаде від 13°С до 8°С,
в інших регіонах - від 16°С до 13°С.
Сьогодні вночі грози прийдуть з регіону Альп,
а в другій половині ночі рушать далі на північ
над Шварцвальдом
і досягнуть гірських регіонів Рьон та Зауерланд.
Завтра вдень ці зливи та грози поступово пересуватимуться
далі на північ за гори Гарц.
У другій половині дня слід очікувати нові грози з Альп.
Це можуть бути справжні бурі, грози,
що супроводжуватимуться сильними опадами:
від 10 до 30 л. опадів на квадратний метр.
А це також знижує ризик лісових пожеж,
принаймні тут, у Баварії.
В інших регіонах рівень небезпеки пожежі 4 із 5.
Завтра температура на Північному морі 20-22 °С,
в інших регіонах - від 23°С до 30°С.
У суботу дощі з грозами підуть з Німеччини на схід.
У неділю з північного заходу наближатимуться
нові дощі та грози,
у понеділок знову потеплішає.
На графіку для міста Фрайбург-у-Брайсгау
можна побачити, що все ще пануватиме
літня спека, хоча і менш інтенсивна,
опадів не очікується.
Гарного вечора.